où
pas
[Musique]
où
on se bat au salon de barbier que j'ai
débuté en 1959 s'est fait déjà 61 c'est
sûr que moi personnellement fermer mon
commerce et pas toujours plaisait mais
quand switcher pour l'heure la santé des
jeunes mais le trio n'a pas le choix
j'ai plutôt un repos parce qu'elles
m'ont vacances existe pas dans mon
dictionnaire amoureux dominé pdci dont
allianz munich le barbier des sportifs
[Musique]
moi juste une aumône open market est bon
bien le show comme maçon chabot levé
j'ai eu des des chambres qui quittent
qui ont percé dans l'orchidée grc au
maire michèle picard ont rendu plus
l'appui elle même présente au
journalisme le diambars et chimiques de
beaux chalets de ses venues que la place
a été fréquenté par beaucoup de jeunes
si je t'assure travail d'accueil si je
t'ai toujours leur faty venons pour
besoin d'appeler pour mélissa plus jeune
j'étais 14,1 dans l'aiguillon majeur du
québec comme relatiosn essais canadiens
jop nationale à laval d'attendre mike
bossy entendent pat lafontaine un temps
claude lemieux a que ça c'est sûr que ça
ait des gens qui m'ont envoyé à ligali
moto club l'olivier a réussi puis
rencontré par notre parti c'est ce qui
fait la place des besoins ici c'est
l'entretien que tu donnes c'est jeudi
si on est formé de 60 membres cotelle
monsieur legault qui me donne le hockey
[Musique]
ceux qui réussissent sont toutes à peu
près d'am nkayi son sein son travail est
bien vite pour personne c'est son faille
tout le monde il n'ya pas de clé pour le
succès ici c'est le travail
la ponctualité la discipline et coûteux
certes pas parfait
[Musique]
j'ai eu un des méchants télévision
balance rose ça ça peut amener quant à
soi et j'en écoutais ce l'émission ne me
pense à projeter et barbie pour la
valette il penser que j'imite ldap dit
que je t'aime à calcutta pour baby
[Musique]
me sentirais comme égaux et ne pas
travailler après parce que je me dis
j'ai la santé je peux pas fermer de
boris et recommencent à 60,1 en santé ça
finit mal
puis j'ai des employés si le respect d
appuyer le respect de la clientèle m'a
dit comme on dit sur monsieur philippe y
en avait à court terme c'est la santé
que le travail reviennent le plus tôt
possible
puis j'ai fait une promesse aussi à ma
petite fille
ainsi à labadie va falloir être assez
attention la lâcheté de promesses walker
on doit faire attention
d'accord on souhaite qu'elles saleilles
le plus longtemps possible qu'on a
profité de l'espace
[Musique]